[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره السلام عليكم الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
يواصل مناقشه التغييرات قارون القضاء وسط
احتجاجات العارمه ورفض النقابي ومع توقف
عشرات الضباط عن اداء الخدمه العسكريه
رئيس اركان الجيش يحذر من خطر غياب تماسك
الجيش على وجود اسرائيل وحزب يرفض مقترحات
اتحاد نقابات العمال لانهاء الاسلحه في
لقاء هو الاول منذ تمرد ديفاجنر بوتين
يؤكد فشل الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
ولوكاشنك يقول ان قوه تريد التوجه الى
بولندا ويحذر من نيه النيتو ضم الجزء
الغربي من اوكرانيا الى بولندا واتهامات
روسيه اوكرانيه متبادله بقصف كاتب رائيه
مدرجه على قوائم اليونسكو للتراث العالمي
في اودس انطلاقه اعمال مؤتمر دولي في روما
يبحث مكافحه الهجره غير النظاميه من
افريقيا وللتجاره بالبشر وليست الوزراء
الايط يطالب بالتعاون لتحسين ظروف العيش
في افريقيا بس هي ما في دول الانطلاق
والرئيس التونسيه يقول ان القضيه لن تحل
بتحركات المنفرده وليس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه في ليبيا يطالب في تصريح للجزيره
بشراكه مع اوروبا لمعالجه قضيه الهجره مع
استمرار موجه التطرف المناخي التي تجتاح
مناطق عده في العالم اليونان تنفذ اكبر
عمليه اجلاء في تاريخها تشمل نحو 20 الفا
من السكان والسياح من جزيره رودس بعد
اتساع نطاق الحرائق الناتجه عن الارتفاع
الشديد في درجات الحراره الى اللقاء